Rich what problems what mistakes do
young entrepreneurs make when they're
getting and trying to get into a
relationship that you see that you're
working with guys very simple she's
pretty she touched my pee pee I'm gonna
date her or marry her or invite her into
my life all right like guys are very
very simple right it's like oh you know
she's giving me attention she's
responding to my texts yeah uh you know
she'll go out with me and have dinner
sort of thing but women are a lot more
complex than that and men are never
taught you know the reality of what
women actually respond to right we're
just taught to shut up get your head
down get to work make the money you know
provide for family pay your taxes all
that good stuff cut your lawn you know
just be a good man sort of thing right
so guys don't really understand the
reality of what women are actually about
so one of the big problems that I see a
lot of guys run into and I've sort of
distilled it down to this phrase with
Chase Excellence not women is guys
especially when they get into longer
term type of relationships that's when
you see guys put on weight they may
start to get lazy one of the main
complaints that you hear from a lot of
married women is
um he you know I just don't see him the
same way as I did before and if you get
lazy in a relationship you don't sort of
move up the corporate ladder you don't
improve yourself you don't maintain a
certain standard of health and the
Optics of masculinity and strength you
know it's not uncommon for a lot of
married guys to be sitting around with
Cheeto dust on their chin or their shirt
watching sports for hours but that's
Homer Simpson that's what every man is
portrayed these days it's good and
that's and that's one of the lies that
Society has sold us is just sit around
as long as you get married and take your
vows you can just sit around and do
nothing right you know it's total
[ __ ] guys have to chase accidents
the burden of performance is on men men
are success objects this is one of the
things that he's gonna be fired up Gino
like I'm about to say push-ups right now
so this is one of the things that Dr
Warren Farrell talked about in his book
he has a book called The Myth the myth
of male power and guys are viewed as
success objects to women so you must
maintain a a certain degree of the
pursuit of excellence in your life as a
guy if you want to keep a woman or keep
women around you in your life women on
the other hand are Beauty objects to men
men know that women don't generally
share their pot of gold with them right
so there's a small contingent of guys
that are like oh I'm looking for a sugar
mama sort of thing but women typically
marry a cross and up so because they're
hypergamous they want to find the guy
that's the better bigger better deal
than him so very very common for a uh
you know CTO making quarter million
dollars a year to wife up uh Becky the
hairdresser making forty thousand
dollars a year and there's absolutely
nothing wrong with it you know if women
weren't hypergamous and you're saying in
that instance Becky's hot and that's
what did it for the guy Bingo yeah yeah
she was hot you know she returned my
attacks she touched my pee pee so we got
into the long term really
relationship and most guys don't have an
abundance mindset they don't have
experience with women they don't
understand you know the reality of what
women respond to why they leave men why
they choose men and all that sort of
stuff so I deal with a lot of that in my
videos now on YouTube and my book and
you know so on and so forth you're like
Will Smith in that in that movie where
he was like the dating expert or
something what was that hitch pitch
except for Will Smith is a dork and
really doesn't live his life correctly I
mean look look what he allowed to happen
to himself you know he let his emotions
get the better of himself and he walked
up on a stage and punched one of his
friends right in the face he lets his
wife go out and bang his son's best
friend okay keep it right there is that
not okay from a subconscious psycho
whatever perspective to me watching this
from the outside I have no idea what's
going on his personal life I feel bad
for him for what happened but
do we not all believe that that's why
that happened like he his wife's doing
things that he's clearly not comfortable
with and he eventually like and people
are in you know the guys out there Chris
Rock's talking [ __ ] the guy snaps he was
probably so penned up and pissed off
because he's living his his life one way
his wife is living another and he looks
like an [ __ ] after he's the
quote-unquote epitome of success and the
dude breaks I mean is that and is that
I'm not a psychiatrist but it looks
pretty clear to me
that's that's the behavior of the
average male today you know they they
don't have standards they don't uh have
control over their emotions and they
allow their women to do obnoxious things
like sleep with their son's best friend
right like what guy
20 years ago would say yeah cuckoldry is
absolutely acceptable in my house it
bothers men there's there's no time in
history where men accepted letting their
woman sleep with other men but it's only
today like you take a look at media
outlets and they're trying to normalize
the pussification of the western male
right oh you know just just look the
other way when she runs around you know
behind your back because if guys are
doing it then women should do it too
right so there's all these sort of lies
that are perpetrated in society that are
getting Amplified and it's demasculizing
men and it's masculizing women I don't
think it's good overall for the
direction that we're heading in but
that's just the reality of the world
that we live in today
I have four questions so for me
you guys want to Buckle in for the real
deep stuff let's keep diving down no but
but when you get hit in the gut
sometimes you got to take a step back
for me and I think there's a lot of
Truth to that yeah but for me it's real
simple I I'm
I'm a Christian believe in God there's
no mention of God anymore there's no
expectations there's no forever there's
no there's no long term isn't left
anymore there's no let's work this thing
out anymore it's everyone cut bait
there's a lot of things that are going
on other than just men screwing up I
think when a man looks for a woman we're
values values-based decision making you
get into a relationship what are your
values men don't even know what our
values are like you said push people and
get together so there's so much more to
it I mean I think as you're a male and
you're young and you're thinking about
this what do you want your life to look
like when we got married me my wife I
have six children we homeschool our kids
we got married my wife already had the
expectation of I sort of want to stay
home you can go to work and I'll be in
the background I'll raise the kids you
know as the kids got older now should we
have the podcast together we're working
together but that's what the expectation
was when we got married not that hey I'm
going to go out become a lawyer and
we're gonna have student debt so I think
all of you men out there what is the
expectation when you start dating what
does it look like for you I mean do you
want to comment on that because I think
that's where the stepping stone is what
are your values and what are the
expectations of this relationship yeah
that's an interesting uh talking point
from the sort of Christian more or less
like the traditional conservative sort
of community like I've you know I've
been married for 30 years we've got six
kids I've talked to a few guys like that
and and that social contract you know
existed for a long long time and I think
religion overall is probably uh you know
good for society I think it's good for
long-term marriages it it seems to be
good for families and children but the
problem with it today is that uh that's
another lie that's being perpetrated so
a very common thing that guys will start
to see more and more on dating apps
today so you can take the average uh you
know 30 year old guy that downloads
Tinder or Bumble and starts to swipe and
he'll start looking at women uh his age
or younger you know typically and it's
not that uncommon to see a pregnant gal
on a dating app with another man's seed
in her belly with two or three other
children in tow from other men claiming
that she's gotten right with God is
looking for a man of God and is and is
in this for something serious now
um only an absolute fool and Tool of
society today would take that on but but
the problem is is that even things like
religion are telling gals well as long
as you get right with God you'll be
forgiven for your past sins or bad bad
choices and then you know here we are
where they try to you know Christian
Mingle them up sort of thing and we know
statistically speaking that one of the
worst choices a guy can make for a
long-term relationship or choosing the
mother of his children let's say which
which is probably a better way to sort
of distill it because that's the whole
point of marriage really is to raise a
family and have children and pass on
your name and your DNA sort of thing is
to find a woman that hasn't made bad
choices in the past meaning she hasn't
been with a lot of guys
um a woman with a notch count as I call
it you know generally today of zero to
one has a very low probability of
getting divorced whereas a woman with a
notch count of three four as it
escalates to 10 12 and they stop
collecting the data after 15 and by the
way it's not that uncommon for a college
age woman today to a slept with 25 or
more guys by the time she finishes
college or university the chances of
divorce increase dramatically and not
only do the chances of divorce increase
dramatically but the chances of her
being depressed having multiple
abortions being on ssris like you can go
right down the scale promiscuity is very
very bad for women but that again is one
of the lies that they've sold societies
that women can be as promiscuous as men
without consequences and that's simply
not true the data doesn't reflect that
and you have an active Channel That's
not shut down and you're saying this
stuff yeah you have to be careful about
the way that you have these
conversations yeah it's it's an
interesting line that you know you have
to walk when you have these
conversations like I was I was doing
this in 2016 and 2017 you know long
before some of the uh like Isaac Andrew
Tate you know I'm sure your audience
have probably heard of you know now were
were even making the prolific bold
statements you know that they are still
today
but it's a fine line that you have to
walk to have these conversations because
when you speak the truth it offends
people like bombers get Flack when
they're over the Target and you have to
be very very careful about when you're
flying over the target I really hope you
guys enjoyed that clip if you want to
watch the full length podcast you can
find that over here that clips from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out